It is home to wait for the Yes Hello google
8 Today is google play charge api tribal beginning with android
not to mention
This is a sequel to the overview of that book api that was broadcasted on August 28
I would like to deliver
google
My name is Ryosuke Matsuto and I am examining developers in android.
Thank you
My name is Yoshitsune, who is in charge of content development today.
Nice to meet you
By the way, I would like you to go around in today and do something like this
Well, I think there were various sources but especially now
While you are providing content in 8 google play
That's right, the situation is that there is a lot of content on the main up Billing Mu
Among them, I bought items for mania items that I often used in knee-up billings, but
Comfort woman billing in
Say that it will not come to the content purchaser of
I will win the award
But why is there a part of it and why is it solved?
Today there are a lot of things there and that
I think it would be like if it could be, but what about it?
Billing is an area where we have a lot of inquiries, so it is August 28th
It is a little part that was not able to talk in detail
I'm going to use that wide board or something this time
I would like to explain while please thank you
There are quite a lot of quick questions in up-billing and why are you coming all the way
High that
Well in the background as a very powerful means to monetize with Google Play
Attention
Is that why there is a background that feels like the expectations of the reblopa
It seems that the company is actually doing great achievements, but even the best Google Play
But I do not come out I'm getting a cup of Google Play
I'm very happy to hear that kind of story but it ends in such a story
After all, I sometimes use that in up-billing
Umpa's reflection is slow, so 8 user reviews are bad and the view is skipped
I can not handle that great claim
We had to expand such a user support team
You will be asked to respond to google play
How can I solve it?
Well, the first thing I want to mention is that the number of inquiries for that child is actually in Japan
Not limited situation
That's what we do
That's right, even when I came for sightseeing, I have a lot of inquiries
Oh, it's great, but I'm also a huge cancellation
There is a delay and you talk about what to do
You've seen it for two hours and three hours
Even people meeting people meeting people in Japan Korea and a situation that is heard
We have received a lot of similar inquiries to google now in America Europe.
It seems that I would like to talk about that a little more today, so I will
Assorted
That's right, could you please enter the slide for a moment
That's right from now on the fact that it will be broadcast on August 28
Well it was a rough explanation of the story why the notification can be sent, but this is this today
It is a crossdresser who needs to talk completely
It's just that I can not send it to me, but how can I solve it?
that
You can tell me the details, so it's true that other than that
This August 28 and this today
google developer and not the live page, so many questions
Because we receive each one,
I bought the question of yes for the question on August 28 after the question of 5 minutes and the truth after a while.
I would like to receive Mr. Rosa after the day
Well then, it will be convex in the same state.
5Because it is the one who reported it
Just explain
Then let's move a little
Actually I do not replace a lot of fun cameras in the same room
Yes
net
Yes yes maybe
Awesome Sanko's
I wonder if it's okay
Hmmm-really
Today is this
Something causes something to be treated as a pride and Africa is used by
While
I would like to explain briefly
Purification
Well first of all, the app calls request purchase first of all.
request
Start with sending to Google Play
so
The problem is that what happens after that moment
So how are we making recommendations for our sample programs?
I would like to briefly explain the existence of
Well that generally
Please change the
Let's write and see
And 8-7 numbers
Ah
There are some 50 routes in some of the things that go out of the app and the moving fortune tellers
go in
activity
In the sample program of that rice field ring
in addition to tbt
In addition to that with the broadcast receiver
There is a module called
Oh dear
Generally in general
Because it is included, from Google Play
It's cool, it's in
It is from google play
First blue for cast receiver
Tifa position in up
A certain broadcast receiver
The app receives notification from the example of the sample program of that sample program example
Then
After receiving that once in service
For 6 pm
get Target Panfes also asserts that the tool that sent the request
Play from site
For cast receiver
artis state change way
I am sorry for the small size
Receive these notifications on the broadcast receiver Yes
In this Peenap beam sample code in general these are forwarded to service
In the service that is 4 to the service and doing rice Shogi in the service
When the result is reflected in the activity
It has become a flow of love
so
If this
Wait
Where can I make a mistake?
As a possibility
It is now said that the role played by Woo
From the broadcast receiver to the service or its Tocky's version service from
It's right when you pass it out to the activity
so
Sound is good by having a lot well
I wonder if this is me
This is great too
Or it does not move if it arrives in the first place
It is said that I can not hear
It seems that the trouble is happening or it is a group day
In fact 8 because there are so many inquiries of that child google but
I am doing a lot of analysis and analysis work
that
Probably he seems to be 5 times in comparison with the food of the inquiry
It is late or not reached
According to the analysis of the google side if the delivery date is not good
I would like to do almost without the result
I'm sending it almost haste, but there's still a record that I'm sending almost as fast
Huh-it was just
that
What are we thinking of being the most angry?
Hunt delivery
Something is weird after sending a book at
What is wrong with something? What is wrong?
After this arrival
When hunting for my brother and I
If there is not enough memory, Google Play is first and foremost
When it comes out to the front of the failure It is the terminal that the memory is not enough
At that time
Well, for example, the broadcast router has arrived but before it reaches service
The app has been terminated due to lack of memory
Or I received the service but before I reflected it on the screen or saved the database
The app was closed when there was not enough memory
If it happens even once
This is the next delivery of this Inap's auxiliaries are now fan's subtlety
From the app
Until it is given, it has become a tumor of redelivery.
If you move even once, this damage is large
If you miss even once, for example the next delivery
If you're lucky few seconds school If you're unlucky you'll be in a few minutes if you're lucky
The user seems to be late as they have to wait forever
so
If it is the best
If you fail to be the first goddess first, then it will be 3 seconds 5
Or after 30 seconds it is spreading like Japanese
That this is not necessarily a sense of trying
Anyway, let's not miss the city bar first delivery
It is important importantly
Yes
The first delivery
What does a large thread to make it go a long way?
If you take it straight as the code
There is a possibility that it may fall out of place, so this is included in the sample code
It is not
that
Oh dear
Specializing in the moment received by the muddy speaker and receiver
Recently google said that please write to a file or database
We strongly recommend the rice
When I write in, I'm going to go see a little if it's a little useless
I went in black and I should go
When you receive 200 power with a broadcast receiver
Dokhan point with blog cast receiver
Well this is ok Well by this company
I use different storage methods each
In a certain s-class light database
In another company, you can use text file
And another business person's life preference
For the time being, as soon as something is received by the blog cast receiver
Yes, if you leave data in the app
so
Even if you write from this service on 8 sites
It's ok
Because I do not know that this service is also always terminated or forced
that
Well this is also a bit still a bit of our evaluation formula
You should write from within the broadcast receiver
I should write here from service
This is still from us
Clear guidance y
It is important not to treat
Take one second, for example
that
If it takes processing
It is said that there is a good chance that the app will end up in the meantime
To
20 I hope you know this is the google play ui still this time
It is said that it appears on the screen as android os
If this idol does not have enough memory
Because shut down is the specification of android
That is not wrong even if this 5 ends
I have to write to the place where it will not disappear immediately from receipt
Say it will mark
I guess things are happening
Well, that's the current understanding from google
At this moment in the moment you actually received it on the broadcast receiver
For example, I wrote bread in shared preferences
Or at the moment of receiving it from the brand cast receiver at the service
It is consumption of how many milliseconds already
Only 10ms or 20mm
I already have a car in between
Because there is a millisecond
Between
It's like writing to the database in a quick attack
I'd like to request processing from google
By
In fact this is some business operators
I think that I was stable as a result of doing this
The story that says
some
As we heard that it was a change plan stay, so that customers can also purchase fairly smoothly
The story that it became
U
After we give this advice from us
I heard that it is right here once
Oh, it's a baby, it's a text file, it's a preference, it's a preference and you write
Whats received
When the app is launched next time
Well, if there is data left here, continue the process and steal it
After you write, for example, continue the process with the service etc, and of course until the end
If you can go
As it is
Let's enter it, but I can't cut it on the spot as it is, and the end
You will delete the data here
Of course we recommend that you have that kind of mechanism
What's important is that
I received it here and write it in a fast attack, so it's Kapiko so I have a quick attack now
The love of notification
Not once in a group
That of the two
Please return it there and by doing so
that
I agree
Well for network saving
There is neither a loss nor a waste of one
It can be saved
I think there is no known data
Save in haste and return there and then 5 os shuts down the app
Also okay
Make this process a guardianship function
This is very effective
It is a story. This is very important and very
Well, that common mistake is that
In the other round
No matter what you save it in memory after receiving
If I try my best to handle my brother and I without saving in the database
It is a pity because I was only in memory when I was shut down on the way
I will not be open until I come back again until twice the good guy fly from the end
It will be said that it will not come out without it
In fact this is
It is the time until the second half marketing of various apps comes back by us
Of
Measure
If there is no problem with the app, change this in a moment for collaboration
After coming out of Anouchi cup to the rush and coming back soon with some app of the body it comes back
It takes a long time until 1 minute
I think
Like that
That things are frequent
Hijon Well
Possibility of failure in the part of this or the reception or this part
I do not know
Because
This is very
Precious
I'm told that this was really quite effective, so the scale
The border that gave me this explanation
In part
If you actually review the implementation and implement it, it will improve significantly
Yes, I would like to mention one more thing
What is saying?
There is no state
From service
I ran for a while, but I was able to finish it
Of course there can also be a state of
In such a state, Inaf notify purchase state change
You can fly and have a professional speaker and receiver.
Is it okay to try something?
Unfortunately in the world
Unfortunately there is something even if you receive something here when activities or favors are not running
I'll come in after I can do nothing
It is good to have failed to receive
One big factor
Become a heart
Yes
Yup
Well this is already
This is only the furious tiger description This very important or not super important
I think that this time around
Yes it's a topic but the remaining time is
Damage to the question and answer sidewalk
Shall we
High in time
I agree
It will not return if it is possible to correspond
I will not return to that chair Yes
Yes that's a little
Here
For 28 days
Delicious
Is displayed and registered
Question that we were not able to introduce head buff this broadcast and this August 28 broadcast enough
If you let me follow you as much as I can today
Measure First of all
I hope the culture of August 28 can be
Let's go
Would be nice
Service service
Hmmm
The question is whether there are a lot of stories
After that I asked about it from before, but about Google Play Card again
It's a card gift that I can not say yet.
Now we only service in the United States Thank you
I am in love with a list of questions
It looks like a day
Let's go to Hydere
Well first August 28 yes my
How is the noise lake west last?
Let's read a little Jaguar taste Get after purchase item with subscription
I received a visit by sending purchase pin formation
The action of order lead restoration which is included in the data of up 3rd place without turn
I sent and visited
in up 3 India data meat rounds with orders do not match what kind of thing
Is it
Oh, this is the case of Ams subscription and the case of usual inapubilingu
If the value you should have in your key is totally different
In that case, please use purchase token as key
is called rid
This will of course occur from the order with another order id etc if it is the next month if time passes
First and foremost
Also in the order
Order Eddy is said to be on the way
It's a phenomenon or this is a specification, but if there is a time that has happened
In that case too
A party called Sudo-kun, which is distributed from Google Play together with the wooden case in the up
Yes based on value
Well there is no problem if you can identify the order
of
By all means this is not a regular subscription
In the case of purchase, I think it is better to use the order id
One of the subscriptions identified a good deal with a purchase token
It is
Yes
User minutes
Is the question of b good on the next page?
Yup
Hmm
It is not
The best I can't work looks good is buying an item with a subscription
When I made a refund, I do not know the expiration date and it remains one month later, but how to shorten the expiration date
Do you have
9 questions
Arai Musei = Tell me why you can not expire even though you have not received a fee
Ted
Oh yeah
It is a question of this subscription
this is
That's why I'm part-time
That's what I did from the checkout unsol
This is a very interesting question
a building
First of all if you give a refund in the middle of that second month
That's all about that refund
Oh that here
google play api spec as the city sells and expires
There is no basic cancellation until the curve comes
In the case of a refund because it is postal service
Stop providing content
If you need it, that control
App this side as you may need to make this
so
If you want to make a refund the soil has arrived to the app or this server
Refund with Murai pi or not
If you find that you can not cancel
so
In this case
Well create explicit logic to stop and not provide more content
Need to
In this
Anyway, the Google Play subscription api itself is
User as much as possible
Give priority to providing content to users who are used by
Of summer
It was something I didn't burn and cut along the way. With Iran
Cosdeco that has become a specification that has not been so far
It was shared very much
However, not only people who asked a question of that child a little here but also stores that asked various other questions
We have received similar requests, so google play continues
I would like to consider it, but maybe it might be
b As there were not many such times in the business of Chapo
As an ellipse
That's why I asked this question because I drank on my new return
OK I got a bit of a question from Tokyo
Yes let's go
The top is scary For users who have been paying for a long time
I'm thinking about discounts and discounts, but I would like to know how to do it and discounts on 1 year subscriptions
Etc
o 5th floor
goo
It is unfortunately not possible to change the price of the subscription if it says it as of now
Change of is the preparation that can change the price for one item
so
That's just getting ready, now you're ready to start offering subscription items
Change the price of &
It is clear that yesterday is the last in preparation
Date and time
If I can not say that Izuke's in the middle of it
It is a situation
If the feature can be launched this issue is quite
It must have been changed for each user
I agree
Well what a meeting may be, but in the middle of the user again j or the next
a
At the time of renewal military or one year of a large family or the like, new child item discount price to its user
It is the best impression he can do most now
At this point in time
Beautiful solution with black api play standard api
So if you have it now, you need to make it agri- culturally after the app
I think so
Yes let's ask the next question
Providing content in a one-time subscription model
If you start studying, can you stop it?
Is there any penalty if you are forced to quit due to circumstances?
ntt is 8 or nr til from google is group
Penalty on a
I think that I mean that it refers to D NA
I wonder if high school will be especially important
I think, from the perspective of the user
8 That's right
There is no such thing that a penalty is defined by the rules.
In light of general common sense, the provision of services has stopped and money
It is said that
There is a lot of people who have happened This will lead to user complaints Yes
is not it
In that case
Right now
Even with google play server girl api to cancel
I can do it
How can this user at the river as possible not to happen between the user 6 tatami
Do you want to cancel
Mouth of procedure is reference
From the developer
It is necessary to do it, and the procedure is google like google.
I'm going to lose the case separately on that day
Well pc or even google bolette's
High pay subscription school that was on the web page
Will be written
Procedure
In the morning
I understand that I was talking
Firmly support that after-sales follow user or
There is a place to get
That's right where it's important
Yes
Feeling ale
It is a thing
Kaname
6 hours for initial settlement of subscription expiration date
The next high was about 2 hours for a grace period, but the actual voice is
The first purchase is at 12 o'clock on September 5 because it became as follows.
The expiration date is 18 o'clock on October 5
yeah
The deadline for 12 people automatic renewal of 5th on October 5th at 7 o'clock on November 5th
The next grace period is not 12 hours for purchase + grace period
It will be added at 18:00 + grace period of actual use deadline
In the question of whether this is the first time you purchased a subscription when purchasing it
Deviation occurs. Deviation of progress and view has been shifted to the next tack and at the time of the next update
Enforcement based on which one
I wonder if that grace period is a plus
this is
This is my own
It is a little different from the movement you are looking at, so this was what it was with the introduction purchase at logo 12 o'clock
Tara
Well May
2 months this
November 5th
Around 14 o'clock in the case I saw
That says
Most of the term was the expiration date
It's never been a long time
As a subscription
The term is always calculated based on the first purchase date The first purchase date
It is two months issue class postponement in light of light
I'm worried that you are doing calculations like +4 months +
It seems like this is growing steadily
And just why I'm getting this 19 o'clock is not enough to investigate this a little
From the person who was there and compare it with a little
peach
I'm applying here for a while or for a while
Oh, let's go beyond the end
Yes it's not charge at all
So I'm asking questions about the earnings story, but Bhub police are on other platforms
Profitability in autumn tends to be lower than app market There is labor to cooperate mainly
Get a free app with ads and have a paid version without ads
Please let me know if there is a standard edition with a limited edition of the limited edition free version and extensions with a plentiful paid version
Please give me
I have a question but
this is
What do you mean
There is a place that seems to be the point where it depends on the point but recently
It is said that after all it is called a freemium model
Download for free and be an item or virtual public
Is it most likely to sell in the form of individual and individual charges?
At the same time, it is quite important to collect the same users for the app
In the way
I do
Profitability of that charge
Some of the stories I am listening to
The fact is that it is almost the same as it is good per user
If you put in sales per person
Business person who does not change so much with other platforms
It appears quite recently emerging
On the other hand
If the sales per person are small for the android, the business operator is still
I'm not here yet
I wonder if this is about to break
It depends on the content
Or
quality
I think there are some hypotheses
Talking about the quality of the app
The post is that
Compared to other platforms
android user base
After the difference
In that content as explained today
Because adjustment does not go well
Charge is good
I think that there is a possibility that it will not be lifted by hand.
Something
this is
that
In general, in-app purchases will last longer
Well paid app and put in the app or entertainment over a longer period
The profit is easy to go up, so one by 9
Especially the Japanese market
In the case of the market in Bangkok, carrier charge accounts for a very large percentage
It is the first time to pay with carrier's payment mobile phone charge for the first time
In the exam that the option is for the user
Google Play as a Doo
For example, Aval's Joy makes it easy for hawks to pay
It seems to be good.
I agree
A paid app is
Of course someday from now on
It is continued as method of offer of offer, but
Now that's tremendous growth is in-app billing, so some of the official version is in-app
It is said that we buy by charge
It seems that it will fit well if it is good to do the laundry
That
Hmm
One good point is that you don't have to put pressure on the terminal's memory.
How far that user's
The terminal you have
There is also one place where that old can go
I think it will be the point in making a business
I can say
Well what's the difference in the audience, for example, android google
I do not ask all users to play credit cards
I'm not writing for not asking I think that the difference due to that may come out the war
Of course it will come out
Toto users are
Spend money
The charge will already come true
It may be easy
The difference seems to come out a little bit
Oh yes
And the part here is still that
I think that there are various parts to consider in various ways, so it is the same at the tasting party again
Well, since time has already come to an end today, it's up to here today that charge
App business firmly on Google Play including meetings
By the way, I hope that you will make it up
Although there is no charge until now, there is still a lot of inquiries.
Note of time of so
I think that I will take up this broadcast
Well, I'm going to subscribe now
Thank you again for your high tea thank you thank you
I will